you looked drake in the face and said
you don't have a consensus hip-hop
classic i'll call freddy gibbs right now
he'll tell you i said that to his face
oh my god you're crazy so then so then
he starts like this dude so passionate
and i respected it because i'm like who
the [ __ ] am i to be arguing with drake
at a bar
you know what i'm saying you're lit yeah
for sure he's like
he's like
pretty much just like you know where i'm
from the music's different and what i
what i do you would never a hip-hop guy
like you would never consider and i'm
like no i think take care is a classic
to me but you don't got a doggy style or
get rich or die trying where nobody can
say [ __ ] you don't think nothing was the
same he wasn't wrapping his ass off
that's my favorite album of his
yeah i mean yeah cause you that you're
the hip-hop guy
that's my favorite album i already know
exactly and i consider that to be like a
borderline classic but but the thing is
is like there's these albums that we
look at in hip hop
that nobody can say [ __ ] to you if you
call it a classic right illmatic doggy
style good kid mad city 36 chambers
right
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy all
these albums if you call them a classic
there's nobody who has a a serious
opinion about hip-hop will question you
i don't think drake has it's split like
if i say take care as a classic i know
50 dudes that are that might be like it
was good it's not a clown you know what
i'm saying but give it like
15 years though
maybe but yeah but like good kid mad
city my beautiful turtles and fantasy
these these these albums are classics
take care as a classical show i think it
is i think but i think that in the
within the hip hop community i don't
think it's a consensus classic i don't
think everyone's like really i don't
think so damn i get [ __ ] and i love take
care and i love drake i was just born in
96 so drake is just being like damn you
were born in 96.
so like drake has been a thing since i
was like nine since you were listening
to music yeah
no i can't yeah literally i remember
drake getting signed you know what i'm
saying like yeah
yeah
it's insane i'm old as dirt bro no